yo creo que va a ser un desafío enorme
para todos nosotros porque en américa
latina' estábamos acostumbrado a que
este tipo de cosas la hagan los que
saben la hagan los que han estudiado
para ellos pero acá lo que se está
diciendo es que la sociedad tiene otras
y otras muchas demandas tiene otras
necesidades de kirchner para el príncipe
su propio futuro y acá hay una evolución
social que no solamente le corresponde a
quien es sino que a gran parte de los
países occidente y donde entiende esa
tarea estamos enfrentando un desafío que
no pensábamos que íbamos a tener que
enfrentarlo y tenemos que superarlo y es
ahí donde la convicción y los valores
están reemplazando a las ideologías la
convicción de los valores está
reemplazando a lo que a un modelo de
sociedad y estas convicciones y valores
finalmente se ha canalizado a través de
lo independiente